Okay, so this is the disputed poster.
Now, one at a time, I want you to express your feelings...
...using "I" emotion language, and no judging, or "You" statements.
I got this poster for Christmas, and I feel I want to see it every day.
It makes me feel like the babies are the true artists...
...and God has a really cute sense of humor.
Come on, seriously that?
I don't like looking at it.
It's creepy and in bad taste, and it's just offensive to me.
It makes me think of the horrible, frigid stage mothers...
...who forced the babies into it.
It's kitsch, it's the opposite of art.
Stop! Let's see if we can just brainstorm...
...and find some creative alternatives that are win-win.
Win?
Yes, thank you, Pam.
How about Angela makes the poster into a t-shirt which Oscar wears?
That way, he can never see it, and whenever she looks at Oscar, she can see it.
Win, win, win.
No.
That's, no.
Okay. Well, brainstorm.
Own the solution.
How about I leave it up?
How about she takes it down?
How about Angela can keep it up on Tuesdays and Thursdays?
Okay, that is called a compromise.